[Music]
deep in the value on this street down
this road and this windowless tin shack
is a restaurant run by one woman whose
dishes are so good you have to wait a
year to try them i'm el zinetu and i've
been cooking cajun food for at least
over 60 years
[Music]
welcome to alzina's a cajun restaurant
with no staff and no menu just chef
alzina in her kitchen and it's housed in
one of the most unassuming places a
former welding shop that was once owned
by her son
turn this into kitchen because i love
cooking and you don't have that
uh big bump in the middle right my son
was in the process of moving it to a
bigger place so instead of closing it he
asked me if i wanted to convert this so
i'd convert it into a kitchen
i want it to be open where i cook
and where they eat because they can see
what you're doing
most of the people that come they want
to take part in what you're doing
[Music]
cajun food i think it's the best food in
the world i always raised on it to me
simple cooking
you start with your bell pepper your
onion your garlic a lot of garlic celery
and then you saute that in a small
amount of oil and then you start adding
your other ingredients whatever you're
cooking if it's a gumbo or jambalaya fry
shrimp what's better than that
as good as that sounds eating at alzenes
can be tricky there are no walk-ins and
reservations can only be made by calling
her on her landline phone thank you for
calling i didn't want walking because i
think i would have been very unhappy i
live a simple life and this is the way i
like my life simple no computer just a
simple telephone i'm booked up until
next year i'm always booked up in a year
advance
and i like it better that way
[Music]
over those 40 years alzinas has been
pretty successful garnering the
attention of magazines politicians and
celebrity chefs people from all over the
world have flocked to alzheimer's
kitchen for her authentic cajun food but
for aussina the experience is all about
making people feel at home like a family
when people come
it's a thin building so they say where
we're at and you don't realize that it's
here
but when they step in the kitchen it's a
different world i really think they are
happy they feel the peace in the kitchen
and then they mingle
family that haven't seen each other for
maybe a year two three years and bring
happiness to them and it bring happiness
to me
i was born to serve
not to be served
[Music]